[Applause]
it's been days in the making thousands
of galvanized on the streets of khartoum
demanding a return to a transitional
government
something they say was robbed from them
after the military coup on monday
they're risking a lot
days of protests in the capital led to
street to street battles with the
military
and demonstrators
we went to the street because we reject
the military rule and we reject
authoritarianism and we categorically
reject all the behavior of the military
council
we want to topple the security committee
and bring it down we don't trust these
people this is not their first coup we
need the world to know that the sudanese
people are living under oppression and
are being beaten our voices are not
listened to because there is no coverage
and there is no internet
with the internet cut off organizers use
mosques flyers and graffiti to reach
people
the military also blocked the main road
to the airport the planned route of this
march
what is really concerning is the vast
you know array of military and security
actors that are on the streets there are
just incredible set of of of security
sectors that now patrol the streets um
no sense that they are necessarily
taking orders from a central spot and i
think that
you know that diversity of different
military actors is really the worry
these demonstrators are demanding that
prime minister abdullah hamdock's
cabinet be restored
it was toppled by general abdul fattah
al-barahan
he also dissolved the sovereign council
established after the overthrow of omar
al-bashir two years ago
says he will hold elections in july 2023
and then hand power to the elected
civilian government
but the takeover has received
international condemnation
the unin us has called on the military
not to intervene in the protests
the people on khartoum streets call it a
power grab and demand a return to a
democratic process
laura about a manly al jazeera